hello and welcome from the Karolinska
Institute of Stockholm where we just
discovered who has received the 2009
Nobel Prize in Physiology or medicine
joining me to discuss this is Professor
Runa Tov gourd professor environmental
toxicology at the Karolinska Institute
professor Toth gourd thank you very much
for joining us so soon after the the
prize has been announced could we begin
by you telling us who's received the
2009 Nobel Prize for Physiology or
medicine so dear laureates
our Elizabeth Blackburn from the
University of California San Francisco
it's Carol Greider working at Johns
Hopkins University School of Medicine
and yak Shostak from the Harvard Medical
School and so what they receive the
prize for so they've been awarded a
prize for the discovery of telomeres and
the enzyme telomerase and how it
protects the chromosomes and so for
people who haven't heard of telomeres
and Selam arrays before could you
explain it for them in simple terms
please so I would say that our genes are
encoded by DNA and DNA is present in the
chromosomes in the cell nucleus and the
telomeres they are the ends of the
chromosomes and they have an important
function to protect the chromosomes and
maintain the integrity of the
chromosomes and so what would happen if
they weren't protected if the Crimson's
were protected by these protective caps
that his telomeres so then the
chromosomes would get shorter with every
cell division and in the end that would
lead to loss of genetic information but
it would also mean that the chromosomes
will be degraded and that will start the
degradation process in ourselves in
eventually lead to cell death
so has profound implications for for
cells and organisms as a whole
what sort of roles what sort of
implications for the organism does
shorten your telomeres have in terms of
normal cell function and disease so it's
evident that this is a fundamental
biological mechanism
and Malaysians in the telomerase genes
have actually been detected in a certain
group of inherited diseases and they are
characterized by difficulty to maintain
stem cells particularly in the bone
marrow so if you have too little
telomerase activity the stem cells in
the bone marrow are at risk and some of
these patients develop severe anemia so
we know about this implication in
disease we know in cell function but the
story in which we discovered the role of
telomeres and how telomerase is
important in maintaining seal of a
length is a story that's told in several
chapters and I wonder if we could go
through each of those chapters interns
discover how he went from from from the
beginning to what we know now and so
that the story starts before the
discoveries were made that were in
reward with him there with Nobel Prize
in medicine and what if you could tell
us a bit about what we knew about how
DNA is copied in the first place so what
was known in the up in the 70s was that
DNA is copied by DNA polymerases and
this is a rather complicated process
when both strands of the DNA thread has
to be copied and it proceeded smoothly
in one direction but in the other
direction it is a stepwise process and
the problem is that when it reaches the
end on one of the strands it's not
possible to copy the very end of the
chromosome and scientists didn't know
how this could occur and how this could
take place and and many different
theories were around to explain it but
in fact nobody knew so people knew about
a mechanism copying DNA but what the
missing piece was held how DNA the very
ends is copied yes and it was also known
that that was very important for to keep
cell happy and alive
and so then we reached the first chapter
of the the telomeres long race story and
could you talk us through the first
steps in the key experiments that that
were performed to that reveal the
existence of telomeres so in fact it was
the billion is about Blackburn were
studied studying some certain specific
types of chromosomes in a single-cell
organism tetrahymena term Orfila
which which then which has these
chromosomes and she discovered and found
that they had a specific sequence at the
end although she was at that time also
interested in understanding how these
chromosomes were maintained now Jack
szostak he had a different problem he
was wanting to make artificial mini
chromosomes and put them into yeast and
when he made such he discovered that if
they were linear and they could not be
maintained in yeast as they were rapidly
degraded so what was happening was that
there was a piece of DNA that was being
discovered at the end of chromosome just
repeated many different times and this
was occurring in an organism that's that
lives in water which is very distant
from human body and another person Jack
szostak was working on yeast and he was
trying to work out why chromosomes he
was introducing its use for degrading so
then we reached the next part of the
story which is the key experiment could
you talk us through that please yes so
as in all good science there are lucky
moments and then one of these lucky
moments was when Elizabeth Blackburn
actual stuck met at a conference in 1980
and they heard and about each other's
results and then they decided to test
the possibility that the EM sequences in
the tetrahymena could actually function
in a very different species yeast which
in in evolutionary terms is far away
from each other and so what happened
yeah so then they made mini chromosomes
just like the one that Jack szostak had
made before but now they put tetrahymena
tell
DNA at both ends and when they
introduced these mini chromosomes now
into yeast cells now they could be
maintained for a long periods of time
and in an intact manner and so it's
quite incredible that the experiment
work because you have 230 different
organisms taking the protective cap from
one organism and attaching it to another
it seemed to work fine yes and I think
that was the one of the most important
aspects of the experiment because that
immediately said that this must be a
very strongly conserved and fundamental
mechanism that was discovered and so the
next chapter of the story involves
discovering how these telomeres are made
in the first place and could you talk us
through that please yes so the
hypothesis was then that there might be
a new and unknown enzyme that was
involved in actually adding DNA
sequences to the telomere ends and Carol
Greider and Elizabeth Blackburn started
a search for the enzyme and so they used
Tetrahymena cell extracts added DNA
sequences corresponding to the telomere
DNA and building blocks for DNA and then
they could actually analyze if an
extension took place and again on
Christmas Day 1984 Carol Grady could
actually detect the first signs of
enzyme activity in her extracts and that
was then the starting point to go on so
it's a delightful Christmas present but
what exactly is the machinery that crate
steven is so it turns out that this is a
unique enzyme that has a protein
component that actually has a catalytic
function and it has an RNA component
that is intrinsic to the enzyme that
serves as the guide or a template to
determine which building blocks that
should be added and in which order so
the RNA access that the template for
construction and the enzyme that's
passed the complex is machinery that
creates the DNA strands yes these two
components are actually sufficient to
make the reaction work in vitro now now
later on we know that in real cells
there are also many other calm
that are involved and and are
surrounding these key components that we
are talking about here and so we have
this this lovely finding in in different
organisms that shows that how the ends
of chromosomes are constructed how
protects the chromosomes from from
degradation we then need to move to how
this is important to to the cells that
are in yours and mine bodies so what was
the next leap of knowledge that we had
in order to know that this is the case
well since there was early observations
that also said that if telomerase
activity was compromised then cells
would actually age or senesce in culture
so it was thought that maybe this is a
key mechanism to aging however now we
know that aging at the organismal level
is a much more complex process and are
many factors that influence aging and
telomere length and telomerase is one
that is important but there are many
others now the other key thing that also
came quite early was the discovery that
most cancer cells have very high
telomerase activity and that is needed
since cancer cells proliferate very
frequently and in one sense can be said
to have eternal life and at the same
time cancer cells also have abnormal
telomeres so that has raised hope that
one may be able to develop new
therapeutic strategies to treat cancer
based on blocking telomerase activity or
to eliminate cells that have high
telomerase activity again one must be
careful also with potential side effects
since it's also now known that stem
cells have telomerase activity and that
that activity is important for the
maintenance of the stem cell compartment
so where are we with regards to
understanding the role of targeting Slom
arises as a potential therapy so early
clinical trials are ongoing in cancer in
the cancer area primarily with two
approaches the one approach is to block
traumas activity and the other one is
actually to try to teach the immune
system to eliminate cells would have
high telomerase activity and I think
there is one phase 3 study but most of
the other studies are phase one or phase
two and so we still have to wait until
we get conclusive results and know if
this will be have a thickest e towards
cancer or not
so the going back to discoveries that
have been rewarded with the Nobel Prize
this year these were made in the late
1970s and the 1980s so is there any
particular reason why the candidates for
the prize were deemed particularly
worthy this year no actually so the
first key discovery was mainly nineteen
nineteen eighty two the second on
enzymatic activity 1985 and RNA
component in 1989 so that is the
timescale but going through different
discoveries and weigh them against
others as it's a lengthy process and it
must also be very evident that this is a
general process and and also then the
Nobel Committee goes through who
actually did the discoveries in the
great detail so there is no particular
reason that it's this year but now all
the knowledge and all these factors that
I mentioned are around and they were
selected to be at the top of the list
this year and one things that the the
achievements highlights is the the value
of curiosity driven research and the
value of high-risk high-reward research
and that's a message has always been
told by the Nobel Prize since 1901 is
this a message that the the medicine
committee's keen to promote more than
ever I think that with the Nobel Prize
in if you solve your medicine we are
very careful to select discoveries which
are of fundamental importance in biology
but also have clear implications but it
is the fact that if you discover a new
fundamental by local measurements it's
bound to have also medical implication
and this is the case also with the
discovery of telomerase and another
important factor is that also curiosity
different search also in organisms that
may see in faraway
from human beings turn out to be very
important in this case a unicellular
organism 'silly ate and yeast but they
were enough to reveal such a fundamental
political process that has all the
importance also in human beings and
that's a great message to end on myself
god thank you very much for more
information on this year's Nobel Prize
Physiology medicine please visit Nobel
Prize dot-org where you can see the
official information about the prize but
also exclusive interviews with the new
laureates as they could appear on the
website that's about it for this webcast
join us tomorrow where we'll discover
who'll be receiving the 2009 Nobel Prize
in Physics the announcement is scheduled
for 11:45 Central European Time
but until then goodbye from all of us in
the Bell prized org
you